is a realization that vaccine is being
made real time
it's coming off the line and
they are projections we have every
confidence that will have enough
vaccines but it's a very human
when you're dealing with biolog very
human process it's uh
biologics have to be made very carefully
so we are making projections three weeks
ahead of time but we
want to be fully transparent um
on uh what we see coming and we are
trying to do that
thank you doctor i guess my last
question i'll try to in the remaining
time
uh ask this question dr fauci if others
wanted to chime in if we have time but
this is really just projecting um the
challenge the biggest challenges you
think we face the most
urgent the most difficult i realize they
can be multiple
and at the same time but dr fauci when
you look forward
just down the road a few months in terms
of just the
the public health challenge we have how
would you
how would you rank or itemize the
challenges that
we face are you more concerned about the
impact of variance or the
or or the struggle to to get people
vaccinated
or uh or is it both or do you have some
other
worries that um that i haven't
articulated and i know you
others may have spoken to this earlier
but i'd like to get your view
thank you for that for the question um
there are a couple of things that
concern me
probably the one that's the most
prominent is
my concern that we will declare victory
prematurely if you look at the dynamics
of the outbreak
it's a very very high peak that we had
following
the holiday season that was expected
to have a peak but not that high it
really went up to
three to four hundred thousand new cases
a day at one point
it's coming down sharply now but we seem
to be plateauing
at a level that's unacceptably high
around 50 or so thousand
cases a day this is what's happened in
previous surges
where you come to a plateau at a high
level
and then you start to surge europe is
generally about three to four weeks
ahead of us in the dynamics of their
outbreak
and what they saw a little while ago was
a plateauing of their decrement they
were coming down nicely
and then they plateaued and just as you
might have predicted they then one
started to go up and a couple of weeks
ago they had a nine percent increase now
they have about a five percent increase
i'm concerned that if we pull back
in our enthusiasm for the fact that
vaccines are rolling out
and things look good if we pull back
prematurely
we may trigger another surge and that
would really set us back and all the
things that we're trying to do
thank you senator casey thank you
senator braun
thank you madam chair uh my question is
going to be for dr fauci and dr marks
uh going to be two questions one you can
sense the frustration from senator paul
cassidy murkowski many of us because we
know we don't have complete data
we know we got to stay disciplined
before we get this thing under control
but in kind of a top level way that i'm
looking at it we've got to get the herd
immunity uh through natural infection
or vaccination i want to make sure that
you can take that
in vaccinations and come up with hurt
immunity if the conferred immunity is
going to be about as good with a
vaccination
versus getting the infection i'm taking
uh
30 million as number of cases tested
would like your opinion on how many
completed vaccinations there have been
and then the big variable how many
untested
cases to get to that 250 million
and like your opinion on those numbers
because when you can give us a little
bit
of certainty or idea on that it gives us
hope like
senator paul said to maybe stay tough
and get through it second question would
be
if vaccinations aren't as effective as
we want them to be due to a cascade of
variants
then do we need to turn our attention to
therapeutics
if this is going to be something we
battle with over the long haul
so so thank you for that question
i i want to just harken back to what i
had said
a couple of uh some time ago to senator
burr and some of the comments that
dr wolinski had made about this magical
terminology of herd immunity
we could get to where you and senator
raykowski and others want to get without
necessarily reaching this arbitrary
percentage
because as dr wolinski said it's going
to really depend on a number of things
because very it depends on what the ro
of
of the virus is and if you have variants
that come in
they'll modify it there are a lot of
things that modify it i like to look at
it in a different way
i'd like to look at it in that every day
we get two to three million more people
vaccinated we also still get people
infected if you look at the number of
people that are protected
we don't necessarily have to reach 85
percent of the population
to get to the things that you were
asking for about your businesses
in alaska and about schools being open
the way
senator collins had said we can approach
that
in a real meaningful way before we get
to this
magical number so i made these i think
there are
untested but out there because to me
that's the big plug-in variable
i'm reading four to five is it four to
five
or is it closer to two or three and if
we have no idea
that's the biggest variable when you get
to that point where you get to what
you're talking about
what do you do in your modeling how many
untested cases
do you plug into the model you're using
no it's see
there really is no model right now for
for herd immunity it's purely an
estimate the only thing
take measles for a second we absolutely
know
what the level of herd immunity is for
measles because we've had
multiple instances where when you went
below a certain level of protection in
the community
you had outbreaks it's a highly
transmissible virus
the vaccine is excellent 98 effective
when you get down below 90 of the
population
being immune when you get into the 80s
you get the kind of outbreaks that we
saw in the new york city metropolitan
area
we don't know that yet for coronavirus
we just don't know what it is
i understand that and what about if it
seems to be a
an elusive thing to get through
vaccinations and natural infection
where do we start putting more emphasis
on therapeutics
maybe i'll chime in there is a
fundamental difference between measles
and covenanting measles is a is a
is a virus that does not vary with time
the way that coveton 19 is varying and
the reason
for having this issue of needing to have
the best immunity you can and
potentially vaccinating people who have
already had
covet 19 is to get to high enough
antibody levels to make sure that as
these new variants come along
we are not uh basically decimated by yet
another
another version of code 19 coming across
the population
so it's essentially doing it right the
first time to prevent another set of
closures which has a lot of kind of
uh uncertainty timeline indefinite and i
think that's the
tough thing i think you guys have to
contend with let's get to the question
of then
therapeutics versus vaccines because
isn't that the way we finally hammered
aids
was with the therapy you know because a
vaccine
is never for for for a global for a
global pandemic like we have here i
think we really have to
probably i'm going to defer to dr
welinski who's more expert than i am but
i think
vaccination is probably don't get me
wrong we need better therapeutics and
right or natural infection right
um i think we'd like to avoid natural
infections because i think
as uh was already mentioned at this
hearing there's
we have this coveted long-hauler
syndrome so i probably prefer not to
have those
those people have those long-term
effects so we'd like to prevent natural
infection
uh by providing immunity through
vaccination
you want to add anything or
i agree completely that the the idea of
treatment as prevention as we have with
hiv doesn't work
because you're dealing with an acute
syndrome that lasts just literally for a
few weeks
virologically you may have persistence
of symptoms treatment is important
because you don't want people to get ill
and we've had 530 plus thousand deaths
you can avoid that with good treatment
but the dynamics of an outbreak
absolutely is going to depend upon the
vaccine
thank you thank you thank you very much
and and i would just like to note the
doctor fought she does need to leave at
12 15 so we're going to try and get
through
as many as we can uh dr uh senator smith
thank you thank you very much chairman i
think you almost promoted me to doctor
but i
i'm not sure um
i want to thank our panelists for being
with us today and um as i've been
listening to the testimony and also the
questionings i'm
the questions that are being asked i'm
thinking about a conversation i had
yesterday
with the folks at hennepin healthcare
which is a safety net
health system um in minnesota level one
trauma center
in minneapolis and uh one of the things
that one of the caregivers
said really has stuck with me um he said
we are just so worried here as we
continue to grapple with the impacts of
covet in this community
um that the world is going to move on
and you know as
i dr fauci and others have said we're
still seeing
somewhere in the neighborhood of about
50 000 cases or more of covet a day
and 1200 daily deaths so i think it's
important that we stay vigilant
and keep our focus and of course also
look to where the good news is and i
think we can do both of those things
um dr wilinski i want to ask you about
uh something
around vaccine distribution this is a
bright spot
so um tribal nations in minnesota have
done an
exceptional job in distributing the
coven 19 vaccine and here's just one
example
the white earth nation um in
northwestern minnesota partnered with
munoman county to distribute the vaccine
and has now this county one of the
highest vaccination rates in the whole
state
and what they did is they had a they
established a joint task force with the
county
and helped to streamline vaccine
distribution
and manage the supply in order to get
the vaccine out
and today white earth reservation where
of course there's a mix of native and
non-native people living
um and is a sovereign nation so they set
their own guidelines
and about who can be vaccinated um today
because of this close
collaboration and the partnership that
they have they've been able to
anyone who who is over 18 who lives on
white earth reservation has been able to
be vaccinated
so um another example is the boy sport
mobile vaccination clinic which is they
have brought this
is a another um northern minnesota
uh ojibwe tribe they have brought their
um their mobile vaccination unit
to tribal members in duluth and in
minneapolis and those who don't live on
tribal lands
so dr willensey could you just comment
on
why you think this is working and what
this can teach us
about addressing the challenges that we
see around the country
and getting an equitable distribution of
vaccines
thank you so much for that question
senator i think
as i mentioned uh several weeks ago we
had a vaccine forum
where we brought people together about
to talk about their best practices
lessons learned how they've been able to
distribute we had over 100
tribal participants um and and i don't
know if those were specific
examples that were given but those are
among the examples where we can
say this is trusted partners this is
community engagement this is people
getting the message from people they
know places that they trust
this is part of why we want to engage at
not the state left not necessarily only
the state level at or
or we need to get down to the local
level people don't necessarily want to
hear from me that they should be getting
their vaccine they want to hear it from
their local pharmacist
they want to hear it from their tribe
members to say we've all been doing this
together they may actually need to have
it
not just be convenient but be able to
revisit it and say well maybe i'm not
ready today but it turns out
tomorrow i've noticed that five of my
friends my community members have gotten
it and
they're willing to engage i think these
are important lessons that we need to be
learn that we
are learning and that we need to
replicate those lessons in not just the
tribes but in other
areas around the country as well as
rural areas around the country thank you
i really i couldn't agree more with that
i think one of the things that's
important about this is that we
sometimes think that what we are
experiencing is vaccine hesitancy when
actually what we are experiencing is a
lack of access
and especially a lack of access from uh
trusted providers so i think it's
important
dr fauci i want to try to get this
question into you uh quickly
the minneapolis star tribune recently
reported that minnesotans are using
websites for
vaccine shopping so they're trying to
figure out what is the best brand and
then
shopping around um for that and trying
to figure out the benefits of one
vaccine versus another
dr fauci what would be your message to
people who were trying to compare the
efficacy of these
different vaccines as they are
making decisions about how to move
forward what would you tell them
yeah thank you for bringing that up
because that really is an
important issue we have three highly
efficacious vaccines with a good
safety profile i think it is not
appropriate understandable but not
really appropriate
to be shopping around to see which one
you could get because you're making a
guess of which one is better the only
way you know
if one is better than the other is to do
a head-to-head comparison
in a clinical trial so my advice when
people ask me
is that what is the most important thing
is to get vaccinated as quickly as
possible
when your turn comes up to get vaccine
which particular candidate you get is
really not nearly as relevant
as getting it as soon as you can so if
you go into a clinic
and they have any of the one of the
three available
i would just take it rather than waiting
maybe a few weeks to a month for
something that you think might be better
all three are highly efficacious
thank you so much thank you medicare
thank you senator marshall
thank you madam chair leadership
is what america is now looking for
they're looking for a strong
consistent honest voice from the nih
from the cdc the fda and from the white
house
and frankly dr palachi a nation is
turning us lonely eyes
to you for leadership let's talk about
schools for a second
i think you all know and agree with me
our schools are our youth are in a
mental health crisis
are used for suffering from increased
instances of suicide substance abuse
overdoses depression
a true epidemic and this was very
predictable for all of us from the
healthcare field that when we close down
schools without the social interaction
we see increased
mental health crisis totally predictable
let's talk about the science of viruses
for just a second as a private
practice ob gyn for 25 years
i would tell you that viruses are
predictably unpredictable
but how they impact a non-pregnant
versus a pregnant woman
certainly is different and what i feel
like when i try to listen
very hard to you all is that this that
little science we do have is being
presented as
dogma as gospel and we know it's not
it's anecdotal at best all i've heard so
far today is basically anecdotal
experiences
when it comes to schools we need to hear
a stronger voice from you
all from leadership we need to hear a
stronger voice not a wishy-washy voice
and dr
fauci i would ask you do you agree with
me that the benefits
outweigh the risk of getting children
back in school
will you tell america we need to get our
kids back to school
i have said that repetitively as you
know you s you've obviously been
following what i've been saying
i've been saying the most important
thing we need to do
is to try as best as possible to get our
children
back to school safely and that's exactly
what i've been saying over and over
again right in this room in previous
hearings i think the chair has heard me
say that based upon everything we know
about the virus the epidemic we have now
do you feel the benefits outweigh the
risk of getting
children into schools across america
well
i mean if you listen to the cdc's
recommendations that's exactly what
they're saying they're talking about the
benefits versus the risk
and as you know their guidelines are
trying to get people
to follow guidelines that will get the
children back to school with the minimum
risk
i was hoping a yes or no answer but i'll
move on to mask
one mask two mask o'meal my you know
president biden recently said that we
should all wear masks until
everyone is vaccinated that's probably
the worst thing that could have been
said for compliance
so many people have said why would i go
get a vaccine when the president says we
have to keep wearing masks
until everyone's vaccinated
we americans feel like the gold line
keeps moving
and i understand your your fear of
different variants and all those
different
different things going on here but where
is the science that clearly shows
wearing mask is helpful
after you've had the vaccines and for
the sake of time i need to move on but
all i've heard you've heard that i heard
the question asked already i've heard
anecdotal
evidence but i would love to have you
all send me the studies that show it's
that that is absolutely beneficial to
wear
masks after you've been vaccinated or if
you've had the virus
and we all want to know you know where
is the goal line when can we stop moving
mask
i want to talk about the border though
that's what i'm really concerned about i
just visited the border my third trip
there
is certainly a humanitarian crisis and
i'm sure anyone that's been down there
would agree with me that it's a national
security crisis but i want to talk about
the health care crisis going on there
when i went down with a group of
physicians three years ago or so i was
concerned about just the doctors and
nurses being overwhelmed i was concerned
about tuberculosis hepatitis
scabies sexually transmitted diseases
and other communicable diseases
but now based upon what we know the
incidence of covet is 5 to 25
of the people coming across the border
and then what i see is they take a group
of folks 50 to 60 people they put them
on one bus
then they do a couple of exams and they
all put them in in some type of a dorm
setting
so if they all didn't have the virus
they soon will and then we
let them go out into the public that
just seems hypocritical
you know the the application you're
talking about for when we can let ships
come to alaska
uh those and the concern about variants
from south africa
that just seems it seems hypocritical to
me
why why why i respect completely where
you're coming from it seems like it's a
double
standard dr fauci are you comfortable
with what we're doing on the border from
an
id standpoint
the reason i i would have to hedge on
that because i'm not really
very deeply familiar with the details of
what's going on
at the border and that's perfectly
honest with you dr marshall
i really am not familiar enough with the
situation at the border
to be able to make a comment if i was i
would whose job is it to know that
i can chime in and say that um i am
aware that at cbp sites that there's
overcrowding and that we need to from an
infectious disease standpoint from a
covid standpoint we need to de-densify
what is happening at cbp
we have been working closely with orr as
our children leave cbp
and move to the orr sites to to work
towards getting them screened and tested
which is why they have you
you know what percent positivity they
have there those
are orr sites are much improved compared
to the cbp sites with regard to how
those children are cared for
who is caring for them and we are pr
providing technical guidance on those
orr sites to to work to make sure that
they are as safe as possible using
mitigation strategies
but do you see the hypocrisy in what
we're doing to america we're saying
i can't have a barbecue with my entire
family on the july 4th i can't have
easter service worship together
um but we're going to let let people
come across the border in mass
numbers and just release them into just
does that not seem
uh hypocritical i think there are two
different situations that we have to
handle
we have to handle in two different ways
and we have guidance and
strategies for how we're providing
technical guidance for the
the challenges that are occurring in the
density of the border
and then we're trying to keep the public
safe using the evidence-based strategies
there
thank you thank you i yield back thank
you very much senator rosen
thank you chairman ranking member i
really like to thank all of the doctors
for being here for their
uh tireless service to our nation uh for
their information for their hard work
and studying and i'd like to just make
this other comment
that most of us here do understand
that data takes time good data takes
time
coronavirus is a new virus it hasn't
been around that long
we haven't collected all the data to
show us what the trends or
variants may be it's of course evolving
and that good data that will help us do
the predictions that epidemiologists and
doctors like yourselves helped
uh to do will be there it's just
a matter of time i appreciate how
quickly you're working on that
but we also have to keep focused i
believe on treatment options
as we have more variants and of course
people will continue to contract the
disease and we want to
we know vaccinations need to go up but
we want to reduce the deaths
if you do contract the disease uh um
you know 5100 nevadans have already uh
over 5100 have already died from covet i
i don't want to see that
uh going up and so i have introduced
bipartisan legislation uh to to uh
to hopefully track a diverse set of
covet patients
long-term longitudinal study and report
those findings on a
regular basis so dr fauci i really
appreciated
uh so much the conversations we've had
in the past
talk about monoclonal antibodies other
antivirals
we know both have helped like i said
people are still dying
so is it an issue of patients not having
access to some of these
and what can you maybe tell us about
what's in the pipeline for therapeutics
for those who unfortunately
uh will may still contract the disease
um i had outlined and i'll briefly
repeat it
in my opening statement that we have
that we have therapeutics for people
with early disease
uh the difficulty logistically is that
getting people early enough to make it
work monoclonal
antibodies clearly work in the setting
of getting people before they enter the
hospital
and before they develop advanced
symptoms every study that's looked at
monoclonal antibodies
after a person has advanced disease in
the hospital has shown
no benefit we do have good drugs
for advanced disease particularly the
state of the art of using dexamethasone
with advanced
individuals we have a number of others
under emergency use authorization
but getting to the point that i think
you're suggesting
senator is that the real end game for
this
is to develop targeted antiviral
drugs very similar to what we did so
successfully
with antiretrovirals for hiv and for
curative therapies
for hepatitis c we are now being
investing a considerable amount
of resources in doing that we have a
couple of candidates now that look good
that actually had been developed
previously that we're putting into phase
1 2 and 2a and 2b trials
so you're absolutely correct we need to
do better on therapy and the
strategy for the future is the direct
anti-rep
antiviral therapies that are similar to
what we did with hiv
thanks well i'd like to build on that
then because we hear about the long
haulers or the long-term effects
of coping 19 we see people
really suffering from this we know about
30 percent of all coveted patients
really continue to suffer from some form
of ill-defined sin
uh symptoms prolonged fatigue brain fog
as some people are calling that
it may render folks unable to go to work
it puts them at risk for continued
social isolation and
other kinds of issues it may certainly
uh decrease
of the uh their immune system and so
um we we have to be sure that we don't
deny
benefits to these folks who have the
long-haul symptom but what can you tell
me about dr crouchy about nih
how you're evaluating uh these troubling
long-term health consequences
and um are there treatments available
what's in the pipeline there for those
that are continuing to suffer
some people's sense of smell i've heard
ransom smell now they get their smell
back but
everything smells sour or rotten um
what are you what are you doing we've
initiated a major
program uh to the tune of 1.15 billion
dollars that we're doing
at the nih also in collaboration with
the cdc
and following cohorts of individuals to
determine
the incidence the prevalence how long
these symptoms last
we have some studies say they go out up
to eight months
or longer you ask a very relevant
question
what about treatment of them it is very
difficult to devise a therapeutic
regimen
when you don't know what the underlying
pathogenic mechanism of the disease
is and that's the real stumbling block
here and why
we are intensively studying these
individuals because although it is an
absolutely real phenomenon
we don't have any pathogenic mechanisms
right now
that we're certain of that has a
commonality among all of them
we will find that out and when we do
then we'll be able to devise
hopefully appropriate and effective
therapies
well thank you again appreciate
everything you're doing uh
madame chair yield back thank you
senator rosen uh coach tuber
thank you senator thank you very much
thank you all for your service kind of
reminds me of my old job
40 years coaching college football
sitting there listening to a bunch of
armchair quarterbacks
everybody's got the right idea what how
to run your job but
thank you for what you're doing because
this uh this country and
i guess 340 million people are counting
on y'all
and several billion that's not in this
country so
uh it's very important and
you know it just brings to the fact
where we are in this country on the
campaign trail for the last two years i
kept telling people
you know this really the last year that
you know
everybody thinks they're going to come
up with a vaccine americans are going to
come up with this vaccine
because that's what we do but we need
leadership dr fauci you're the
tom brady of uh of the covet team
uh you've had good days and you've had
bad days
and we thank you for what you've done uh
we just need leadership from you and
consistency
you know everybody that i talk to you
know they understand where you're coming
from but sometimes we change in
midstream
you know coaches can't do that you know
you you gotta you gotta stay what you
believe in so
so uh we just asked you to you know just
be firm with us tell us you know you had
people in here today
senator uh rand talking about the mask
tell us what you believe what and
because we know very little about it
you know the american people don't know
anything about it dr malinsky you've got
a
you got a tough job in front of you and
thank you for taking it on
really again this is not a republican or
a democrat disease
you know this is this is a worldwide
disease and we our kids are hurting
i will tell you that our kids are
hurting uh i've had
friends that died i've had uh people go
out of business
we got to get we got to get this country
back open as soon as we can
i mean we we can't we can't drag our
feet much longer but we can't put people
in harm's way either we really can't
so thank you for what you're doing uh
i'll reiterate reiterate what
mr marshall said senator marshall said
about
people in alabama can't understand why
we're letting people in
when we know some of them have the
coronavirus we're a loving country
we like everybody my god we put our
lives on the line
our country on the line our businesses
and
everything else on the line for the last
year and for some reason the white house
continues to let people in with this
virus and it's just mind-boggling to us
that pay taxes everybody that pays taxes
that
will help them this ain't the time this
is not the time to do it
and i think it's your you guys job is to
go up there
and say listen what are we doing we
can't do this anymore
we got to get the people back to work
and kids back in school and go back to
church and get back to normal life
and we've just got a double standard
here right now that's just
it just amazes me but again i don't have
any questions thank you for what you're
doing
uh we're looking up to y'all and and
tell us what to do
please tell us what to do and how to get
through this because we
have a lot of people in trouble mentally
in trouble
not just physically but mentally thank
you very much thank you mr
chairman senator can i make a comment
just in response to something that you
said is really very important
when you have a static situation that
doesn't change
when you do change your mind then you're
flip-flopping but would you have an
evolving situation when the scientific
evidence and data
roll out and you learn more things in
march that you didn't know in february
that you know in january
that's the reason why you may hear us be
saying things
that seem to be different from one month
to another because
you make a decision you make a policy
you make a recommendation
based on what's going on and the data at
the time
so i just wanted to say that because you
make a very good point when you were
talking about consistency
we try to be consistent but we have to
be consistent with the data as it exists
jame the game plan changes doesn't it
you bet if you're playing against the
zone
or you're playing against a man-to-man
it's different you're exactly right
you're exactly right but when you do
change it
sell it yeah and stick with it right i
mean that's what we're all counting on
thank you we're counting on y'all thank
you appreciate it sir senator moran
senator uh gentlemen ma'am thank you for
being here thank you for your service to
our nation um
dr marx it's nice to see you i'll see
you in the fda in the appropriations
process and dr kessler thank you for
your help
in regard to helping us with the care
for veterans
uh and we have uh we're working to pass
legislation past the senate last night
with a conversation we had in our
hearing about spouses and caregivers
for veterans so that that issue that i
raised with you is
is progressing uh and uh dr fauci i
didn't have enough of you in the
appropriations process so i've joined
the
health committee great to see you thank
you very much
let me just ask you a question uh and
then i
i think i'll i'll visit with dr lewinsky
um
it's going to be a bit outside of covet
19 all that's related
so you better than anyone know the
resources
that nih has devoted to combating covet
19
uh the research and the response uh i
i'd like to be reassured
that despite that important work that
the other things
that are important to america that are
led by nih research are not
suffering so how would you how do you
see the overall
picture at nih during this time of covet
19.
i i think i would not be totally frank
with you if i told you that things
are just exactly the way they were prior
to covet
senator there has been a diminution of
activity in some areas for the simple
reason
that a lot of the clinical center for
example is not going at full capacity
for reasons that relate to the outbreak
itself
as far as our grantees on the outside
we are continuing the same sort of
support for all the other diseases that
i know you're interested in
cancer heart disease diabetes
alzheimer's parkinson's
all of those are going well but i think
across the country
the same way that other areas of our
society have been dampened down a bit by
this outbreak
i think some of the research endeavor by
the very nature
of when you shut down you shut down a
lot of things
including accessibility for example of
certain types of approach
but i want to give you my absolute
promise
and i'm sure that dr collins were he
here he tell you the same thing
we give you our absolute commitment that
we will do everything we can to make
sure
that nothing important slips in the
other areas of research
uh it's a matter of saving lives uh with
covid and
outside the the other afflictions and
diseases that americans
are afflicted with uh let me turn to uh
the cdc dr walinsky
um it seems important to me i mean
i've heard the the while i have three
hearings going on this morning at the
same time i've heard
most of the testimony and responses to
questions
and we i certainly am a promoter
promoter and
proponent of people being vaccinated uh
and i think that the cdc could be
helpful if
there are guidelines for uh instructions
and
suggestions for those who have been
vaccinated were
current uh and uh consistent and
timely so what is it that
cdc would tell someone today that that
their behavior
or conduct can change or what their
behavior or conduct should be
following vaccination thank you for that
question senator um
about a week ago we released our first
guidance on
uh first step on what you can do if
vaccinated
and that included things like small
visits in your home
visits with other vaccinated people
unmasked and undistanced so that you
could dine with other vaccinated people
in your home
you could also visit with unvaccinated
people as long as people in their home
don't have
a risk high risk of severe disease
so that is um we are still looking at
data regarding whether people who are
vaccinated can be asymptomatically
infected and potentially transmit to
other people
in that case we wouldn't want you to be
living with somebody who was
immunocompromised on chemotherapy and
whatnot because we were
we would worry about severe disease in
that household we've also released
guidance on
um the fact that you don't have to
quarantine um
if you have been exposed and you are
vaccinated um so the the quarantine has
gone away with regard to
people who are being vaccinated we're
revisiting what we should do regarding
uh travel for those who have vaccinated
and that should be coming forward soon
that's
going to likely be the next step in this
regard i want to remind people that
we have now 12 of the population fully
vaccinated 39.9 million people
the initial guidance was released when
we had nine percent of people vaccinated
so
as more and more people are getting
vaccinated as we are getting more and
more data about the implications of
vaccination with regard to asymptomatic
infection
and potential transmission those
guidelines will continue and emerge as
you're requesting
let me suggest in the two seconds that i
have left that i
had left five seconds ago that
i would ask you to be concerned this is
true for every
agency here as a that's represented here
a rumor in today's social media world a
rumor about a problem with a vaccine a
consequence
which could be false but it is easy for
fear to spread among americans
you need to be prepared with the science
and medicine
to respond quickly to put down a rumor
and i hope that's the case in all of
your circumstances
thank you senator moran senator lujan
thank you so very much chair i really
appreciate that dr fauci um before i
begin with my questions just wanted to
ask you does
wearing masks stop the spread of covet
i'll prevent this protocol bit i'm sorry
sorry i didn't hear your question
someone
dr fauci does wearing masks helps stop
the spread of cobit
absolutely should people keep wearing
masks
absolutely i think there's a reason dr
fauci that even physicians when they're
in surgery and practicing that they wear
face coverings to because it stops the
spread of infection and i think it's
important so just wanted to make sure
that we gave you time to clarify that
after some of the previous questions um
that have been uh
asked today um dr fauci first to each
and every one of our panelists including
yourself
thank you for what you've been doing to
save people's lives
and to defeat covet 19. there are a
couple areas where i do have some
concerns
and it's based on some of the data
according to the cdc
native american and latino populations
living in the united states
are more than twice as likely to die of
coping 19
and more than three times as likely to
be hospitalized as their white
counterparts
despite this data showing us that
communities of color in the united
states have been
hit the hardest by this pandemic latino
and black people are receiving smaller
share of vaccines compared
to the larger population on february
19th dr fauci you said that that racial
disparity was very disturbing and i
appreciate that
given the recent polling that there is
little difference between racial groups
in terms of how much they want a vaccine
how can the federal government and will
the federal government
increase access to vaccine and latino
native american and black communities
this is a major initiative uh senator
that the administration the president
himself is
very serious about and it has to do
with any of the number of things that
are being put in place to
allow equity and easy accessibility
for example community vaccine centers in
areas
that are demographically represented by
minority communities
community health centers the same thing
having pharmacies that are stocked with
vaccines
in areas where there are representation
of minorities to a high degree to have
mobile units to go out
into the community particularly in those
areas that are underserved
and to increase the number of
vaccinators
people who can put vaccine into people's
arms
be they military be they retired
physicians
nurses and health care providers this is
a high
high priority for the administration to
include
equity into our vaccine program
appreciate that response and while i do
have some concerns
and questions surrounding the decisions
that were made by hersto with the
initial
250 sites that were identified including
the first 25
i appreciate the expansion of those
sites to 750 which has expanded
more sites in new mexico including in
rural communities
with that being said dr fauci i believe
that the cdc social vulnerability index
a measure
that takes into account racial and
socio-economic factors and also rural
communities
would be a useful index to allocate a
certain percentage of vaccine doses
to address these disparities the state
of new mexico has designated 25
of vaccine doses based on sbi and i know
it was announced last month that fema
has partnered with cdc to launch
vaccination sites
based on their svi uh yes or no do you
agree that using
svi as a measure in allocating vaccine
doses could potentially help address
vaccine disparities i i think it would
senate i would
probably uh ask dr wellinsky since it is
a cdc
issue if you have any comments on that
yes we are using that we are using svi
as a
mechanism by which to include um fema
sites we actually look at
in collaboration with fema to uh look at
both census data to make sure we're
getting
large populations as well as svi we have
a benchmark svi
we're also looking at the svi data for
distribution
um we we know we have we have work to do
in this area and
while we're looking at the data we also
know we don't need the data in order to
improve because we know we have
improvements to make
and i raised my concerns about hearst's
initial decision with the first 250
sites that were announced the rollout of
the first 25
and the first 250 new mexico which is a
large geographical state
that has many challenges was only
identified with one
center dr kessler and dr wolenski can i
get your commitment today that future
programs
focusing on vaccine equity will serve
not only underserved communities and
urban centers
but also theirs and those in rural
regions as well
maybe i'll just chime in here and say
that um i was really pleased yesterday
when cdc announced 2.25 billion dollars
in funding to
uh to go towards testing in
uh in areas of that needed more in with
regard to health equity
this was the first time that we've been
able to directly give 19
of that funding specifically to rural
jurisdictions and so that effort is
intended to reduce disparities increase
testing increase mitigation strategies
and education and actually leave
a workforce capacity in those areas
so can i get your commitment to future
programs we'll make that commitment to
rural regions as well
senator the answer is yes i appreciate
that thank you that's what i was looking
for
and very much appreciate uh the
explanation there thank you very much
uh chair and i you'll back my time thank
you senator lewand senator bird you have
any
questions thanks senator murray uh guys
we're
we're at the end um i do want to make
some comments that sort of
tie together much of what we've heard
today
senator kaine said about
a reference to a woman maybe she didn't
read the science
well i'm going to tell you something you
already know most americans don't read
the science and if they do
they're like me they don't understand
the data and
i think there is a lesson to that
and that is that when we put out
guidance when we
make suggestions you can reference to
the science but you have to say it
in a way that the american people
understand it
so it's not just the guidance that we
need
it's an explanation in a common sense
way as to why that's
the guidance today uh so that they can
come
that they they can apply that to their
own lives
two senator murray said something really
important
that we need to do everything we can to
raise the confidence
of the american people to take the
vaccine to
you dr wolinski guidance contributes to
that
to dr fauci where he hear
a simple pitch of if you take the
vaccine
the data shows us you won't die and you
won't go to the hospital that's the most
compelling
argument to make to the american people
today that i can think of but we
don't use plain words like that we come
up with something that's way too
expanded that references something
versus something that the american
people will understand
now these are my comments
i hope the vaccine policy will change in
the not too distant future
with the appropriate focus on
geographical
underserved needed areas where the
policy is
we're going to stick the next person in
line
now that we've addressed long-term care
facilities congregate care
the most at risk i fear
david that in the not too distant future
we're going to be sitting there with
vaccines and no arms to stick
based upon the inability of the american
people to sort through this or the
frustration
of staying all night up all night to try
to get your reservation at cvs
and you finally say i'm just going to
wait until it opens wide open
i may be wrong but what if i'm right
and i i just implore all of you
to begin to think through at what point
do we pivot where we say to the american
people
if you're over 17 then the vaccine is
available to you
you're gonna might have to go stand in
line you might have to get a reservation
but i remember the day i walked into a
hospital that
their specialty was a bypass surgery and
when they explained to me that the first
two surgeries in the morning
actually spent the night in the hospital
the night before i i was
older to this and i said why and they
said because if we
if they don't show up on time for their
pre-op then we miss
two surgery windows and those surgery
windows are
our profit we break even that day if we
miss those two
well if we miss that next person in line
if we have to wait five minutes to stick
that person
we haven't maximized the limitations
that we have
of people professionals that can load
that syringe
and stick it in the arm and i think
that's going to become more and more
a concern
lastly well
this first with what we know today
our goal of everybody who would like a
vaccine by the end of may
i think it is fairly easy to say the
american people
next fall schools should open and they
should all be in person
i think it's fairly easy to say
by the time we get to summer americans
should fly and they should feel
comfortable
on an airplane i think we should be able
to tell people to plan their summer
vacations
i think we should say next thanksgiving
and christmas plan to spend it with your
families
both immediate and and extended
we have to accept the fact that our goal
right now
is to be fully vaccinated then and
dr winsky i'm not saying travel to
germany or travel to wherever because
we're at the mercy of their vaccination
schedule
as to when we open it up but let me just
say to you
providing some certainty for next
thanksgiving next christmas
next school year even even if the cdc
policy or
the administration policy is not that
we're going to open all schools
today we can
sort of lean out over our skis and say
but if everything goes like we've got it
designed we can open in the fall or we
can open in person
and there are a lot of parents out there
that will be relieved
and teachers are on notice and students
are on notice uh
last thing um
i recognize the fact that when a year
ago when the pandemic hit
businesses altered what they did and how
they did it
schools altered what they did and how
they did it
government altered what they did and how
they did it congress altered what we did
and how we did it
the one thing that did not change at
your agencies was the responsibility
for everybody to show up to do their job
for a year we've been reliant on the
health care professionals that work for
you
with you and beside you to do their job
if not we would not be here a year later
with three vaccines
we would not be here with ample supply
of of uh
syringes and all the accompanying
devices and and ppe that's needed
to carry out the most massive
vaccination program
that the world's ever seen um we
wouldn't
be in a position where we could be
talking about let's look around the
corner and see how we prepare and
what we learned from this so i i
ask you all to go back to the people
that work with you and for you
and thank them on behalf of this
committee and this congress
because without them we would not have
the ability to have hope
uh that this could soon be over
and we wouldn't have a commitment that
we could explore
how to make sure this doesn't happen
again so i thank each of you for your
testimony today thank you for your
indulgence manager
thank you senator burr and what senator
byrd just said i think is probably the
most important thing
we have said to all of you uh in this
committee hearing thank you to
all of your staffs everyone who's been
working really hard on this and
uh appreciate all that they're doing so
thank you for bringing that up
i just have two additional questions and
we'll close the hearing
first of all dr marks i wanted to ask
you
for a year now your team has been
working around the clock and
making sure vaccines and therapeutics
are being developed and are safe and
effective and
we are all grateful for that work but an
important phase of this work is making
sure that vaccines are safe for our
children
and i know vaccine manufacturers have
now begun work on clinical trials in
pediatric populations
can you update us quickly on what fda is
doing to authorize or approve vaccines
and therapeutics for children
thanks very much for that question so um
the
all of the manufacturers the of the
three currently authorized vaccines
have plans either they have clinical
trials ongoing or about to
to start uh trials in children there are
already
uh trials very advanced in the
adolescent age group that is
12 and over and so there's hope i think
as dr fauci said that
we will be able to get that population
vaccinated for the fall
for junior high and high school students
and
for the younger children we do this
stepped
uh program of the trials will look at
the older young children and then move
down and that's to make sure that we
don't injure any children as we
are looking at the vaccines we have to
make sure that every step
is safe and we don't skip any steps um
because obviously the safety of our
children is
is paramount so i think we have we have
a good program in place we're working
um uh with uh the operation uh to make
sure
that um that uh that program really will
move through
um and i'm the hope would be that by
towards the end of this year we'll have
data
uh in the younger children okay very
good thank you very much and
and dr wolinski this pandemic as you
know has been especially deadly for
communities of color
and has exasperated long-standing health
and equities
recent cdc data shows that black and
latino people are more likely to die
from coven 19 compared to white people
in order to address these disparities
effectively
we need to collect complete reliable
data that fully reveals the scope of the
problem
unfortunately we are still dealing with
incomplete race and ethnicity
data when it comes to coping 19
especially in regard to vaccinations
and even when we do collect data it
often doesn't break out in important
groups like
native hawaiian or pacific islanders i
want to ask you what is the cdc doing to
streamline
data reporting and make sure it includes
information on race
and ethnicity from the states and other
entities thank you for that question um
i think there are numerous components
there
first of all i think we need to realize
that we know we have a problem before we
collect the data
so we're actually actively working
toward
resolution of some of these issues even
without seeing the data we know that
access to vaccines is
is more among the white community than
in the
communities that have been hit hardest
hit so we need to act before we even see
the data but we need data as well we're
a data driven organization and we need
to see where the data are
when i came in there were at least seven
or eight states i believe that
actually their data use agreements
didn't allow them to report data to us
that was in uh racial and ethnic divided
so we've been working closely with those
states to make sure that we can resolve
those data use agreements so that we can
actually get those data
once we get them though that's not
actually the only challenge because in
fact
patients don't want to report and so we
have a
we have providers who don't ask the
question um many of these states
uh data forms say unknown and so we
we get you know the race and ethnicity
data is checked off but it's said
unknown and that's not particularly
helpful so we're working with a lot of
states to
ensure that we can maybe get rid of that
slot so that people have to
to report it we are working to try and
encourage people to report their race
and ethnicity data
one way that we've been able to do this
is through the electronic case reporting
forms
so those reporting forms and we've been
scaling this up over the last several
months
actually can link the test positivity
with their medical record
in cerner or epic which actually report
the race and ethnicity data so we're
working hard and i think this is going
to be a key component of data
monetization
okay thank you very much for that
explanation um
that ends our hearing today and i really
want to thank all of our colleagues
and our witnesses dr fauci wallansky
kessler and marx
for a really thoughtful discussion i
think everybody wants you to say it's
going to be over tomorrow and
nobody can predict that and i know
you're all working really hard to make
sure we have the best scientific
informative information that we can to
make good decisions about ourselves and
our
in our nation um for any senators who
wish to
ask additional questions questions for
the record will be due in
10 business days on thursday april 1st
at 5 pm
the hearing record will also remain open
until then for members who wish to
submit additional materials for the
record
and this committee will next meet on
wednesday march 24th
in dixon 4 30 at 10 am for a hearing on
the nomination of cindy martin
to serve as deputy deputy secretary of
education
thank you again to our witnesses
committee stands adjourned
disagree i don't know that the media
makes it as bad as it seems to me
okay so i disagree with the whole
yeah the statement that i mean it makes
it worse
i don't agree with that right because
your next the next statement is blacks
and other minorities do not receive
equal treatment as whites in the
criminal justice system and you strongly
agree with that
yes so um in terms of
uh your opinion right i mean you
understand that
um or it's your belief that
discrimination exists
yes and that it's bad yes
and that um as a result of that
discrimination
uh black and other minorities do not
receive equal treatment
you would agree with that yes all right
so the question becomes is
because based on that opinion right is
that gonna
is that going to affect your judgment of
this case
if this case is not about race at all
for example right
and it's a question of police practice
and cause of death
are you going to in is your judgment
going to be
impacted by your opinions as to
discrimination
in this now so if
if a police officer has an interaction
with a minority does that automatically
make it discrimination
um you also i think have a fairly
healthy respect for law enforcement is
that fair to say
yes um the question is presented
where the statement is presented police
in my community make me feel safe
and you strongly agree with that yes
um you there's a statement a similar
statement that says i do not trust the
police and you
somewhat disagree with that
i don't distrust the police okay it's
that one
yeah i mean i guess you the police make
you feel safe and you strongly agree
with that right
but when it says i don't trust the
police you don't strongly
disagree you can somewhat disagree so
i'm asking i guess
what's the what is it that gives it
gives you some reservation to say
i don't trust the police they're human
okay fair enough um
which my last question on these
statements there's a statement that says
[Music]
because law enforcement officers have
such dangerous jobs
it is not right to second-guess
decisions
they make while on duty and you somewhat
disagree with that
so there would you agree that converse
is true that there are circumstances
wherein police decision making needs to
be examined
yes
if a if a person testifies and they're a
police officer
do you give their testimony more weight
simply by virtue of the fact that
they're a police officer no
i think you said they're all human right
exactly
um you indicated uh or you were asked a
series of questions
about both black lives matter and blue
lives
matter your opinion about the statement
black lives matter is somewhat favorable
and your opinion as to the blue lives
matter
is somewhat unfavorable so i'm gonna
i'll read to you what you wrote with
respect to black lives matter you wrote
i believe that black
lives do matter and that this group is
trying to highlight
the injustices done to black people
especially for just being black
stand by that proposition yes again
i mean um knowing that this
case uh if i were to say this case is
not about race
right right um can you set aside your
perception of the black lives matter or
the blue lives matter
and judge the case based on that
yes
fine ma'am you were asked do you want to
serve as a juror in this case
you checked the box not sure and you
wrote this is an important case
the decision made by the jury will have
a national consequence
that is a heavyweight to carry no matter
the outcome
so let me ask you can you uh envision a
situation
or can you envision the very real
possibility that your verdict
may be not guilty yes can you likewise
envision a scenario where your verdict
would be guilty
yes can you apply the presumption of
innocence
yes will you yes i will
so you know to put it in in another way
pay is terrible right to be a juror
uh it's a hard job it requires a lot of
attention
why should you be a juror in this case
i think i can be impartial and
listen to instructions and go with what
i'm given
and ignore the outside stuff fair enough
if i may have a moment your honor
you